[Music]
I've heard before that you are frugal I
don't know
how frugal that you can be careful about
money which is sensible wait who told
you this because now this makes me
worried it's all over town oh my god but
you're a cheapskate all right no I'm
just curious well and first of all I
think people like to hear that kind of
thing it's you know it's it's
appropriate and I'm like they're
deserving of a tip yeah I'm a good
tipper that that doesn't have anything
to do with it but yes I'm very frugal I
use a lot of coupons use coupons like
coupons almost exclusively shop with
coupon well yeah you do most of your
shopping with coop yes well the best
coupon you can get and possibly in the
world is the Bed Bath & Beyond coupons
cuz they're called like 20% off and if
you go and buy like I do they're an air
conditioner or whatever you could be
saving upwards of $80 this sounds
incredible are you getting paid by the
Bed Bath & Beyond people no I wish yes
if mr. bad mr. bath or mr. beyond his
interest I think it would be a very good
partnership but I have been very
addicted to those coupons for quite some
time and I'm not I'm not saying I did do
it but I may or may not steal them out
of my neighbor's boxes sometimes because
you go to your neighbors homes and you
take the Bed Bath & Beyond coupons a
allegedly that's something you might
have done I I wouldn't have done it in
the dark of night but if I'm walking my
dogs past and I see it sticking out I
may or may not have grabbed it more than
once that sentence can be taken out of
context
[Applause]
you know that's the part they're gonna
run with on you know well and they
usually do yeah so so Bed Bath & Beyond
and they have everything you need I love
that story everything i black out when I
go in there absolutely as you walk in
and it's like all the way to the ceiling
and it's like a warehouse and it's just
dreamy and everything smells like
laundry sheets and it's great it's
wonderful
went out again I swear none of us are
getting anything from Bed Bath and
Beyond and should anything show up we
will refuse it but I will say that I've
been sent there a few times by my wife
and I end up buying a lot of stuff I
didn't know I needed like all this stuff
at the register they put that stuff out
there for me and me a little thing that
goes around the bristles of your
toothbrush to protect it from germs yeah
absolutely
doesn't cover the whole tooth right
that's ingenious we have sterilizers
they have all those different kind of
like cups cuz you don't want to use you
know plastic water bottles all the times
they have like all these cool oh it's
just it's overwhelming Taco Bell is also
pretty good
[Applause]